well if you had covid-19 a recent
medical study found there is an
increased risk of dying from a heart
attack but professional
clear exactly why the virus is causing
that increase Ryan Matthey joining us in
studio tonight with what he learned
today Ryan yeah Brian Denise Cedar Sinai
Hospital went back 10 years finding over
1.5 million heart attack deaths
Nationwide now nearly three years out
from the pandemic start that study shows
all age groups are seeing an increase in
these deaths and the hardest hit those
who aren't supposed to have heart
attacks
my son is like one of those kids he's
definitely into video games Erica Lauren
has a 15 year old son he's a straight A
student doesn't like to exercise and has
gotten coveted twice you can try your
best to prevent things you can do like
the diet the lifestyle the exercise but
sometimes there's a genetic component
September 2022 study by Cedar Sinai
Hospital showing that getting covid
means a higher chance of having a heart
attack and dying it shows all age ranges
are seen the increase but specifically
younger people are nearly 30 percent
more likely young people aren't even
supposed to have a sudden Cardiac Arrest
Dr Christina Madison is associate
professor of Pharmacy practice at
Roseman University and it's even worse
if you've had covid more than once but
what's specifically about the infection
professionals are still studying it but
what they know so far so it could be
scarring from from the inflammation once
the infection resolves could be leading
to that it could be inflammation of the
art or it could be blood clotting she
says but none of which'd caused by
getting the shot there isn't any
evidence right now that the vaccine is
associated with sudden Cardiac Arrest
but until the cause is determined
parents like Loren remain concerned for
themselves and loved ones I can't
prevent him necessarily from having
covet even if he's vaccinated or he's
not vaccinated he still may get covered
now I asked the Southern Nevada Health
District about what we've seen
county-wide since covid the most recent
information they have available shows
death rates due to coronary heart
disease was actually on the decline
prior to 2020 unclear what this looked
like in the past two years Brian Brian
thank you the doctor added the
importance of eating healthy to exercise
on a regular basis a lot of activity and
movement and most importantly do seek
medical attention if feeling ill